[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
like faster are we supposed to know what
the truth is anymore is irrelevant
obfuscation is key
i think i'm gonna be sick all day
homosexuals
which lies they will be spreading
there's no knowing where they're going
singing their whole
platforming
are they
doesn't matter
once it's trending
not a shred of truth is showing
from the investigations ongoing are the
overlords still eyeing accusing the
president of spying
yes the content they keep demonetizing
for big death kids are lying but we're
certainly not trying because through mud
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
you see that steam going no oh no you
can't i guess you can't hey i i forgot i
had forgotten how creepy the willy wonka
film is it is i mean not only is it
terrible and i i used to do a whole bit
on it and then john melanie did a very
similar but not saying he ripped it off
but i would do it for years so we all
know about the grandparents and how
awful they are and the fact that there
was basically child slave labor for
years and then all of a sudden some free
chocolate bars the grandfather can walk
what a piece of crap but willy wonka
that man needs to be in prison yes oh
you uh you you ate uh you ate the gum
when i told you not to so now i'm
killing you
all the all the test candy just hurts
children yeah that's all it is yeah and
he's poisoning it yes every time oh if
you drink the soda you'll go up into the
chopper fan oh no well just don't give
him soda that sends him to the chopper
fan
seems pretty simple it's almost like
it's your factory and you know exactly
what you're doing all right well you
have to weed out everyone else yeah all
the other kids that won a golden ticket
yes yeah that's
there at some point wasn't kids like
wasn't this just supposed to be a tour
what yeah this is like squid games
i wouldn't even want to leave as a kid
with a chocolate factory i'd be like i
really don't know how to run something
like this i appreciate the offer
i'm 11. i inherited this yeah i mean i
don't even know not to mention i looked
at your sheets and i mean just riddled
with debt
wow i can't even take out a personal
loan you want me to run a chocolate
factory i don't want it with with tiny
dwarves yeah i get to kill kids too is
that what you're free yeah seriously
what i'm supposed to be okay with the
fact that you just kidnapped a bunch of
pygmies and then you're just gonna pass
them off to me
seems to me like you're just looking for
a fall guy willie
it's a river of chocolate yes do you
have any idea how expensive that is you
know what gas is going for right now do
you know how much more expensive gallons
of chocolate in a river which by the way
you only set up so that you could drown
a child and suck them down a tube
they're on to my plan it'll never last
[Laughter]
i'd completely forgotten about it until
i watched the whole intro all right it
is terrifying
so we have a lot to talk about today
we're gonna this is one thing and i know
it's not okay people always want what's
trending what's the hot take look
go with me on this we are going to be
talking about and comparing
president uh president jimmy former
president jimmy carter with uh former
vice president joe biden and obviously
uh he's sort of the standard bear
president jimmy carter for worst
president ever
well worst post-presidency ever and then
worst president ever both he holds both
titles he's a two weight class title
holder
and
biden is really really close and it's
happened really quickly and some of the
comparisons we're gonna try and draw a
straight line not only economically not
only militarily but um are shocking yeah
so in other words if if you're if you're
watching right now and you know
your parents most likely uh remembered
jimmy carter this is your jimmy carter
and keep in mind jimmy carter led to
ronald reagan and we'll get to that so
my question to you uh right now first
question of the day is who do you think
is actually worse not who do you dislike
more and i'd like to see a comment
before we get to this segment
former vice president biden or jimmy
carter and then after the segment if
your opinion has changed
shocking former vice president has his
eyes on the prize yes he is the top
contender yeah he says jimmy carter hold
my beer exactly yes that's how i feel
about it yeah
is jimmy cart no yeah habitat for
humanity yeah i don't know he was a he
wants you to know that he was a peanut
farmer like yeah he did it for two years
between 90 years of being a career
politician
oh we get it you're a great man you put
a sweater on in the white house yeah he
put a solar panel up and then reagan was
like go get that off the roof yeah
first order of business take that down
throw it on him why president reagan
because i'm not a puss i don't know this
isn't a big calculator and it's 1980.
yeah unless you can spell boobs up on
that thing
which you can't i tried
[Laughter]
nancy is there with a crystal ball let
me try okay the big board uh also if
unless we let you know look that we are
not doing a show because sometimes we
just get banned from youtube what has
happened six times in the last year now
for two weeks suspension
monday through thursday 10 a.m eastern
you can watch us on mud club ladders
crowder.com mug club at 69 for students
veterans military we're going to do an
extra hour of show today and of course
rumble rumble the free show is on rumble
nothing would make me happier than to
never have to stream on youtube again
just imagine what truth we could
actually speak yeah well people who uh
subscribe to my club know they do just
yesterday that i mean the facts we were
spitting on siegfried and roy wow
totally true hold on to your butts
actually completely true yeah 100 true
he was he was he was killed he was off
he was off by the guy he was a siegfried
whichever one sick free to roy who was
killed by the tiger was killed by the
other lover i don't know the point is go
watch it yesterday we had a venn diagram
before we get to that gerald a how are
you sir i am well how are you i'm you
know i'm okay and uh dave landau you
know him you love him follow him on
twitter at landau dave how are you sir
ahoy good how about you
a little concerned but uh you know if we
need a sticker on the thing but we'll
talk about that later oh this yeah it's
not it's it's the off-brand it's the
off-ramp yeah yeah it's reverse holo
association yes it's the outlet
the action you're actually one of the
few non-billionaires who plays polo oh
yes that's true i do play
water polo mainly yes yeah exactly marco
polo really yeah really honestly you
cheat yes he cheats yeah we have to
cover his face in a wet basement just so
he doesn't look and then he then it's a
hazard he drowns like all the women in
uh you know
charlie the chocolate face yes
okay so before we get to that though
here's something this is a we want to
watch this this is this is the state of
insanity in our country a little bit of
a palate cleanser
no no before this is it really i was
bitching on monday or tuesday that gas
went from 369 to 389 overnight remember
yeah
well it was 409 on the way in here yeah
you feel like
it's like five bucks now for a premium
yeah i i i saw it higher really yeah i
thought it was higher 409 yesterday and
i think it's a little higher today i
keep and the problem is i drive a
relatively large vehicle so i keep tr
it's like trying to pick a stock where
i'm like well i don't want to fill up
now it'll it has to go down at some
point now i'm like damn it damn it i
should have bought yesterday
yeah then you're on the side of the road
without gas what goes up must come it's
still going up or yeah wow
okay or ups all right so uh anyway i
just i'm angry
really yeah i'm mad about a lot i'm mad
about the state of the country i hurt my
knee uh but mainly the country
so
i feel like it's the opposite
no it really is it's not it's you know
it's it's the country i catch you i give
too much that's the problem that's okay
and they just take i'm like yeah gift
just take bum i'm going to be like a
poddling on the soul chair by the end of
this
you see what you're doing to me
all right
uh
let's go to the state of this country's
a palace cleanser this lunatic
interpretive dancer which is not a thing
despite them trying to make it a thing
it just means they couldn't make the
dancing cut
actually has a point
who do you think runs the world girls no
not even close since the 1970s
two corporations have gobbled up most of
the earth's companies vanguard and black
rock so we have a monopoly inside of a
monopoly what the hell am i watching
vanguard and blackrock own coke and they
own pepsi they own apple and they are
watching mary katherine gallagher get
less sexy
they own american airlines they own
delta they own oil and they own solar
call me a
dingleberry but if you own all these
competing
companies in the
free
market then i don't think
the market is um all that
free
okay thing is
she's insane but she's actually right
that's where that's the
that's the tipping point in the country
when all the crazy people are correct
yeah
it's like a psychic finally getting the
name right when they've said like nine
b's like uh barry uh bruno uh bob that's
it how did you know yeah she looks
familiar though yeah you were saying
mary catherine uh mary katherine uh
gallagher right yeah do you have that uh
he flashed it did he flash it
he did i thought it was see i actually
thought it was uh it was vera de milo oh
girl
are you ready
all righty
let's start with the stress that's her
and
okay
now you try
[Music]
see how those big breaths just weigh
them down
he was hilarious in his prime and today
he would consider that sketch cruel yes
unusual very funny at one time it was
very fun no one was more aware of their
physical body and space than jim carrey
oh no unbelievable physical comedy and
now he's completely unaware of emmy
space body time well he's almost as
certifiable as that broad in the
interpretive dance video but he thinks
she's not completely wrong so let me
give you a little recap here of what she
said or you know let me give you some
substantiation because she doesn't
provide her references like we do at
leadercode.com 34 trillion dollars in
assets assets are managed by five
companies that's vanguard blackrock
state street fidelity and capital group
that's around one and a half times the
united states gdp blackrock alone these
are the people who've been buying up all
of these homes right that's why the
housing market is not an actual market
they want to create a permanent class of
renters they are screwing you out of
purchasing a home
anyone out there who owns a home you
know what you can comment below how many
offers have you gotten on your house i
know i have yeah way way above asking
price or market value it's not coming
from a person it's coming from a company
like blackrock so these five companies
do run
way more of your life than is
appropriate now before you say oh see
that's a problem with capitalism no no
no that can't happen without the
interference of government and uh don't
worry
there to fix it is socialist for the
little guy elizabeth warren um who
believes that blackrock needs to be
designated and keep in mind what this
means it means bailed out with your tax
dollars blackrock according to warren
needs to be deemed too big to fail
designation of what is what gives the
fed its increased oversight power is
that correct
is that correct
yes and is blackrock currently
designated so that it receives that
increased oversight
it it isn't designated but i think it's
important to understand that that means
it is not receiving the increased
oversight from the fed
so my question is are you currently
looking at designation
for companies like blackrock nine
trillion dollar companies like this when
the party is going strong it's the job
of the regulators to take away the punch
bowl
ah okay so here's the thing
she believes and this is the current
democratic party that it's worth it with
more regulation and more oversight well
what does that come with that comes with
shackles that comes with never-ending
supplies of tax dollars you know who
needs more oversight big banks oh you
narrate a bailout in their history you
know who needs more oversight airlines
you know who needs more oversight health
insurance companies
all of these auto manufacturers they all
eventually get bailed out by you the
american taxpayer so you get screwed in
the housing market then you get screwed
when they screw you out of the housing
market and they can't pay their bills
you get screwed three or four times
there you go but it's worth the
oversight kind of like gas prices but if
you want to own a home now you have to
be at least half a million dollars and
your car is 80 000. yeah wow really good
it's the american dream i don't care if
you have a nice car right now you need
to go sell it and get an electric one
and spend more money correct well that's
why i said 80 000. oh yeah well some
people have eighty thousand cars right
now eight thousand dollar cars are there
eighty thousand cars i'm like yeah jay
leno
which i only did with my stand-up money
yeah no one cares you should spend all
the money i'm gonna understand my
lightning money because i can always go
back to your stand-up did you see my
nine million dollars
that's spot on god
insufferable but much better than the
current house and no one hates me more
than i hate me me me
anyway okay keep painting so here's
something that is happening
internationally though and you should
know about this i'm surprised i haven't
covered this more in the media but okay
are you ready as soon as the words left
my mouth i wanted to punch myself
um yesterday a conservative candidate uh
in uh south korea is it is it you uh
yoon sekyo yun
i'm saying it the english way because
i'm american
elected as the new south korean
president
so conservative can't which makes sense
because conservatives are harder on
north korea yeah if you actually should
be right these people actually can look
across the fence
and it's it's like communist wilson yeah
it's like ah you want to kill us got it
so wanting to send a message uh so
that's what actually happened and you
know
okay we can talk about that more next
week
the funny part is north korea released a
statement and photos of kim jong-un
inspecting the country's space agency
just like they have look at this
look at this
look at what he's doing i love that he's
five foot nothing and his pants are
still too short amazing he should have a
tailor by now you'd assume right it like
kills him and he's trying to do with the
hair it's like he's trying to do james
dean but didn't quite get it right do we
have that that's what he's trying to do
the hair and the jacket you're tearing
me apart
i put my car down
he's got the cigarette in his hand like
i'm cold what a viper's
was that lower he's dressed there can we
bring it back up kim jong-un bring him
back up look at that he's going like a
greaser it's like lower east side story
oh right there it's uh it reminds me a
bit of donny brosco it's like this is
sunny brack i'm sunny rice
i'm here to see if these uh satellites
are rear or fugazis
it's reservoir year of the dragon yeah
say hello to my say hello to my
middling very average friend
what do you mean funny like a crown
i do i muse you ping pow boom ping
leave the gun pick a fortune cookie
take off your shoes it's their culture i
ain't taking off my shoes for me
i'm taking my shoes off for nobody
by the way he gained all that weight
back
did he yeah look at that yeah he is a
little bit chubby now oh i guess those
austerity measures never kicked in no
i just can't believe he's smoking i've
never seen an asian man do that no i
can't believe it it's unhealthy unless
you show him it doesn't really yeah if
you're a god yeah well he's immortal
don't you know the first time you played
golf he got uh he got 18 holes in no he
got like 12 holes in one oh come on
because it would be unbelievable if you
said 18. yeah
then what is silly when you're trying to
convince me how do i convince people
that i'm a living deity like ah 12 holes
in one did you watch that what was that
movie with ray romano and gene hackman
where he's the president and they keep
throwing the ball out of the moose head
or something
like he watched that and he's like
that's how i want it that's right that's
it yeah
yeah colon two maybe but it's a couple
yeah just a couple i still under par
even
even if i wasn't well holding one i'm
still scratch
[Laughter]
the lighting's cool it was really you're
really close it was 11 holes
wow
wow how useless is this how useless is
this knowledge why do i retain why do i
retain that i don't know it's hilarious
there's something important you're
forgetting because of that now because
it's shocking how stupid someone is
[Laughter]
it's just why would anyone believe that
well because he'll kill them if they
don't right yeah exactly
smoking them sitting there just bring it
up one more time just bring up the
picture of kim jong-un one more time
it's just so funny that they're like oh
no we're in trouble and acting someone's
gonna be hard on us quick bring out the
bomber jacket
yeah it actually it all turns into a
breakdance exactly
cardboard
what is this anchorman and they're about
to get into the fight in the alley and
he can't do the spin so people just grab
him by his feet all right we go
clockwise counterclockwise we didn't we
should have planned my mother was a
saint
so the thing is with you know things
heating up with uh north korea you never
know this is true you never know when
kim might decide that it's the perfect
time to unleash one of his nukes okay
well maybe not so this just brings back
to light more so that russia has nukes
that might actually function right
um so there's no better time
look a lot of you don't realize that the
stuff can happen
okay and you need to be prepared there's
no better time to prepare than now
[Music]
what the hell are you doing man oh thank
you for asking i'm saving your life
there's aliens outside oh that's good so
you're crazy and
you have me in a it's a bunker yes
a bunker no i'm not crazy
crazy would be building the ark
after the floods come are you gonna take
advantage of me
uh i already did that hours ago when you
were asleep that would explain the pain
would you please just let me go
i could let you go
but the aliens will kill you how about
you stay for dinner
i'm a little less worried about the
aliens and more worried about you
touching me when i'm asleep uh there are
aliens
and i have bunker food oh good bunker
food great is bunker food's gross i
don't want it at least try it it's ready
hour from my patriot supply this is not
just some run-of-the-mill bunker food
this is the real deal
if you don't like it i'll let you go
you'll let me go if i don't like your
bunker food
all right are you serious
deals do
okay
this is marvelous right
am i eating in a restaurant thank you
where's the maid ready
wow
you know what
i think i will stay a while
good
why don't you get some more
you sleep it
[Music]
that was like a happy ending it is yeah
yeah glad they got it unlike willy wonka
where it's just the death of whatever
nine children and one who's grossly
unqualified now manages
foodstuffs
which is going to kill more children
it's like yeah willy wonka too listeria
probably a billion in debt being hoarded
off on a little case
good luck working it off but seriously
though um you guys can go to uh prep
with crowder.com and uh you get 50 off a
four week emergency food kick that kit
kick kick kim jong-un to the curb just
be ready uh 50 off prep with crowder.com
and you know what i've talked about this
before too you don't have to be a
doomsday prepper i lived through the ice
storm in montreal and we didn't have any
food so i always have just at least four
weeks i i typically have like three
months of emergency food water and like
a little kind of whatever we call it
like a gas burner yeah it's a good idea
to have you guys have now lived through
the pandemic you see what's
i don't think russia is going to do
anything here in the united states
especially if we
step off
uh but it's always a good idea anyway to
be prepared okay
speaking of prepared um seems like
society at large wasn't prepared for the
experiment that was
the vaccine i don't give a rat's ass if
i get kicked off youtube today if i get
this screw you
[Music]
but you're only using facts yes
so i don't do you remember the fda
actually um they said that they would
need 75 years
to redact and release documents on their
conversations with with pfizer yeah i
think pfizer was pushing that
information right hey just don't release
this for you know like ever you know
jfk's information we'll have that before
right
we'll have the jfk well look spoiler
alert it was ted cruz's dad ah well we
know that now
well i mean
i think it took a month to get the
vaccine it takes you 75 years
yeah there's a lot of paper walking
that's about it
there's a lot of them you have all those
sharpies so this just happened i think
yesterday the fda was ordered to release
10 000 pages on the first of every month
um and uh this happened uh or whatever
the first of every month okay so march
saw the first release of these documents
oh good so let me give you some
highlights here on the vaccine and some
of the uh
results
this is just from december 2020 to
february 2021
the rollout i don't know if you can do
the math
that's not a lot of months
42 000 people were confirmed to have
over and fifty eight thousand adverse
reactions that's over twelve hundred
fatalities and this is from only a
couple of months that they really really
didn't wanna release
wow so people were having like two and
three adverse reactions yes i'm if i'm
yeah you're on that 42 000 people but
158 000 adverse reactions to it over a
three month period yeah huh
it seems significant i saw that on cnn
probably during that time if we went
back in the wayback machine and looked
well and let's for example when people
often now say well the booster you have
to go you have to get a flu shot every
year right so that's what it's being
compared to now even though it's an you
know mrna it's not the same thing as a
vaccine actually you don't have to
people just scream at you yes exactly
doesn't mean it's legitimate right again
but i'm i'm a people pleaser well i
don't know why i say let's go with that
you're a man of the people let's go with
the flu vaccine let's compare it there
were 4 500 adverse events in 20 months
with the flu shots not fatalities so 158
000 adverse reactions
from december to february with kovid
20 months
4 500. that's 4 500 to 150 something
thousand wow
now here's the thing um how many of
well this is something that's
interesting too if you look at the chart
i don't know if you can bring this up uh
one of my researchers found this this is
out of how many vaccines too right you
would want the reactions out of how many
vaccines that gives you a percentage
could be a million from december right
from december 2020 to february 2021.
that information is redacted so we don't
know the total number of vaccines
we have no idea as to what percentage of
administered vaccines resulted in these
40 something thousand people 150
something thousand adverse events now
i'm not saying that that means you're
likely to have a bad reaction but it's
not outside the realm of possibility
158 000 is not a mundane detail michael
well it would be helpful to know so that
we could go oh yeah no that's no problem
at all why would you redact it like
what's the well it's just slightly less
than most of them right yes just
slightly less than
all of the other months well
or knowing the total number of vaccines
that's fine say hold on a sec this is
the question that needs to be asked if
you know how many adverse
reactions have occurred and by the way
you're only releasing this because you
were ordered to
um
why do you not know how many vaccines
were it's almost like you would know
that number first as a baseline because
you're injecting people
i want to invent a drug and just go to
the fda and go now listen it's only
killed almost fifty thousand people
right
and they're gonna be twelve hundred
twelve hundred yeah the adverse
reactions i mean i mean come on fifty
thousand adverse reactions twelve
thousand are dead what do you think put
it on the market uh how do you feel
about no legal liability sold done
you're a tough negotiator what is it no
no no no no no no
i hear 150 000 reactions 150 000
reactions only december february so
those killers
fund and buy all of the shots you
produce yes
you get to keep the profit the fda is
the movie casino where they keep taking
the application putting it on the bottom
of the pile yeah that's all it is well
the problem is with the fda then you
have other drugs that are been sitting
on the shelf for a decade because they
don't have the right lobbyists they
don't have someone who's powerful in
washington dc and i think that people
should look i think people should have
the right to take medication that may
harm them i think it's the government's
job to make sure that people know the
risk they're taking yeah the job of the
government is very simple it's to keep
the people safe from external and
internal threats that's a legitimate
purview of government that means things
like wars if we're invaded that means
making sure that nobody internally is
abusing our system which could cause
irreparable harm particularly physical
harm to other citizens so it's the
government's job to say all right look
this can hurt you whether it's a vaccine
whether it's a a chemo drug whether it's
tylenol the point is that's a legitimate
role of theirs
okay they shouldn't be able to tell you
that you can't put something in your
body if you want to take that risk
they're doing the exact opposite where
they're not letting you know the risk
and they are forbidding you from taking
drugs should you want
to take that risk and by the way
we know that uh there's this there's
this redaction um in here it's based on
these federal exemptions from the foia
request fya requests for people who
don't know so
in other words the government isn't even
requiring of them
the one thing that government should
require of them
transparency yeah transparency that
would be very nice i'm not asking that
you ban the vaccine i'm just asking that
you make sure we know how people are
reacting to it right at what point is it
not crazy for someone who's like i don't
know if i want to take the risk oh
you're one of those conspiracy 158 in
three months 150 000 in three months i
don't think that's insane yeah well it's
steven i think they the the one that
they selected is that this would hurt
our stock price therefore we need to
redact it yes so that's i i mean don't
quote me on that i'm just an inference i
don't wish i'm guessing yeah if i was if
i was gonna wager again yeah if you if
you had hindsight of right now yeah i
wish i could just go before a court or a
judge and i said did you uh i don't know
did you run this uh car off the road and
shoot this uh pedophile on you know
whatever february twenty second as i'm
using cain velasquez as an example but
i'm putting in the first person
perspective
and i would say you know what
i think that might hurt my stock value
in the community and so i choose to
redact that information it's good enough
for me yeah fair enough you're honest
there's a video of it but uh we're
actually gonna gray out the person so
you can't see who it is and he's like
wait a second seem important no we can't
do that you're not blackrock
you actually have to obey the law you go
to jail we just bought your house yes
by bot i
it'll be way more if you ever want it
back you know what just because i don't
like you i'm going to rent it out to a
pedophile it'll be like a battered
women's shelter only for the pedophiles
i call it the red dot street
everybody gets one yep and wait uh you
know what just to just to rub salt in
the wound it's now ronald mcdonald house
how do you feel about that oh come on
now the pedophiles are still there yeah
it's sort of a hybrid
red dot pedophile slash ronald mcdonald
house ronald's son lives upstairs
a real creep at least he did until willy
wonka killed him all right yeah
he gave him gum
yeah that's all he did
why are you licking the wallpaper yeah
it's rude now you're licking the
schnazberry all right here's something
else too
test holiday and then we're going to
we're going to get to biden versus
carter
but i'm j this is just
what do you think what do you think the
founding fathers would think looking at
this this country
and you'll understand once i
show this stupid thing
um
we just talked about pfizer and vaccines
we talked about gas prices okay we've
talked about you know one and a half
times the united states gdp
being managed or run assets under the
you know the purview of five companies
and them being too big to fail
we're going to talk about biden and
carter and the single biggest intrusions
in our economy that we've seen in modern
american life
and all that's bad
but this is really bad so tess holliday
went on tamron hall's show
to uh
it's just another example of truth
doesn't matter
to talk about her now in case you're
going like
before we run the clip tim the toolman
because people are going to make an
assumption tess holliday went on this
show
to uh disclose and sort of help the
public talk about her struggle with
anorexia and i know what you're saying i
must be thinking of the wrong test
holiday no you're thinking of the
exactly correct test holiday and yes she
claims to be anorexic here you go i was
like i'm fat like when you think of the
term anorexia you associate it with
emaciated bodies like you said earlier
when you have so many people saying
things to you online i'm tough as nails
but it gets to you and you kind of you
it's i would be lying if i said that it
didn't affect me and so like your blood
it was extremely isolating it
was
[Music]
uh
lonely
and never be that long
like today i tried to feed myself didn't
do that great and um
plus size or not we all everybody
deserves food everybody deserves to eat
you know
yeah but there needs to be a cat
we deserve to take care of
without judges ourselves
do
yeah you know what if her body could
talk
she's like we deserve to take care of
ourselves the body's like i know
stop
stop
i love the host we deserve to live
without judgment well that's the whole
point we're trying to stop you from
becoming you don't deserve to live with
lying look you're like i know most
people think that anorexia is uh
anorexia is an eating disorder where you
don't we're either you lose too much
weight or you lose too much weight too
quickly that's what anorexia is
now he's like malnutrition of your
entire body right you've got hair
falling out you're it's it's very sad to
just
try to jump on not well jump
slowly walk on it yes bandwagon
right
waddle be crazy i would now like to
change the definition of anorexia to
include this well when do doctors just
say no yeah no you don't get to do that
why because that's what anorexia is
you're the opposite of that when to
visit them they have to take out a wall
in your house yes
yeah you know what have been helpful
when you were younger and instead of
hearing that it's okay to be you all
shapes and sizes do you you deserve if
you heard somebody say hey you need to
work out you need to be careful because
this is going to be a problem for you
you're going to continue to get bigger
if you just keep eating don't listen to
these people that say it's totally fine
and totally healthy which is exactly
what we're doing and why we bring this
up yeah so this doesn't happen to
another person well we used to
acknowledge this universally i can't
believe i'm saying this because i'm
actually implying that that she serves a
useful purpose can someone get michelle
obama in there with the let's move on
and she was right though i mean yeah she
was right about that she says it and
then it's fine now you now should be
like well i don't mean to pass judgment
look the problem here is a you're
diminishing right people with actual
anorexia okay it's a problem and it is a
problem that requires care and help by
the way the care that someone uh with
anorexia would require is not the same
as you would okay just to be clear also
it's wrong to tell people that all body
types are
are healthy i'm not saying
that you can't have different body types
of course but there's a pretty wide
spectrum that fits within the parameters
of health do we do we really not see how
this ends up generationally the problem
there there's no one there to say
no right yes yes and i was anorexic yes
yes yes and i really had to make sure
you know i had peop you cut you probably
cut out any of your friends who told you
you're not anorexic and that's why
you're still allowed to go around saying
you're anorexic because that host didn't
you know what the host's response should
have been
huh
no one's gonna say that
i just figured out what kind of host
well typically something's wrong with me
i think we're missing the elephant in
the room stephen name that movie line i
know jay liver oh sorry sorry i didn't
die from the audience
i thought
[Applause]
that whole movie tragic true story of
anorexia yes yes yeah what were you
saying
you were talking about her response and
she's like i think we're skipping over
the elephant in the room
there's the hostess oh but there's a big
problem i know it's it's kind of funny
it's like you
the problem isn't
that you just eat too much the problem
is that you think that that was a
healthy lifestyle for so long and you
didn't make a change to it and that's
sad for people but it you have to be
honest about it and you have to call it
out and say look the problem is that
you're not eating right now and of
course you deserve to eat you know what
these eat you know what these people
never do you know what these people
never do what i mean by these people i
mean grossly overweight people who want
to tell you that it's healthy right no
one's picking on chubby people here what
i mean is grossly overweight people who
also ironically not ironically just
entirely predictably believe in
socialized healthcare yeah and that you
shouldn't be denied for pre-existing
conditions even one that's in how about
a pre-existing condition that's entirely
preventable how about that you know what
these people never do they never provide
you with a calorie log they never
provide you with food in and exercise
they always tell you and i exercise and
i eat healthy and well then you are a
miracle of science
we just don't know what to do and they
paint themselves into an octagonal
corner when they say and everything else
is fine you know i don't have anything
wrong with me well then well then what's
i'm stumped yes
we are all stumped it would be one thing
if you said i have a thyroid condition
which still wouldn't i mean look i have
a lot of you love thyroid conditions
that's not just glandular her body
treats kale as sugar yes
how it is yes it's obesity you obesity
eucharist that is if somebody there
weighed like 75 pounds and was dying was
like well i'm morbidly obese and we all
just played along yes it's the exact
it's crazy that anybody just sits there
and goes yeah you are anorexic we people
need food we should clap we should clap
that's a good point you're just like
that uh carpenter singer whoa you suffer
from the same affliction that's weird
yeah remember when they were saying that
doctors shouldn't go you and women
contributing problem right doctors are
like hold on pause
uh we're gonna need to fire dave because
i was literally about this this is two
times in the city
the exact same thing
mama cass i was like right away okay
scary go ahead no i already said it's
like doctors can't even ask you about
your weight being a problem when you
come in like yeah just generally don't
feel good okay well let's start with um
i don't know where to start i can't say
the thing that's obvious i can't
i can't even have you fill out a
questionnaire yeah then think about it
it's age that's rude to ask a woman okay
sex you really want to go down that
route
wait you know what uh
just do here's a bunch of pills
good luck good luck
there's only three spaces for numbers
and seats on the couch
there were yeah do you have love this is
a russian couch
what kind of stupid chair is this it's a
it's a gigantic pull-out soap yes
it's what it's what we use to transport
whales
it's a horizontal hammock really it's
how they get them back in the ocean yeah
i want a love seat by that i mean seats
i love and the seats i love have nine
seats
so bad really more of a daybed bed
oh god so all right we're going to start
talking to about
it's just none of this matters
this is the issue the key issue of our
time is truth in the media be the media
is just as complicit and big tech
with
the freest and fairest and most secure
election in history you know disagrees
with that jimmy carter um
just like they're complicit with russian
uh russian pissing tapes on president
trump which they've now admitted project
veritas uh just did a
segment on that i think we'll maybe
bring it up next week it doesn't exist
and the media's been complicit it's it's
it's being complicit in a lie just like
they are when they say yes yes you're
healthy
also well you're not you're all you're
anorexic but now you're healthy good
good great you're lying to people and
you're killing them do you hear that do
you hear that that's the sound of tess
holiday dying as we speak and you're
doing nothing and you're telling more
kids
hey it's the equivalent to telling kids
light up
wow we did that for a while how'd that
work yeah we did that now we're just
replacing that with little debbies we
got people walking around thanks it was
a great yeah
you're urn needs pallbearers
i'm thinking of actual pallbearer
and when case holiday it comes for the
casket
he can be there
the undertaker would have to be lifting
it come on the little guy's not holding
that one yeah they'd have to use the
owen heart harness yeah
with better yes okay all right so look
hey
that was not a slight to owen hart no no
no of course not no i don't know look
dave and i louder with crowder.com tour
if you are watching and you like what
you see you can see uh more of this and
worse live with dave and i uh stand up
and then also some uh some uh
some do an old duo act see so may 14th
we will be in tulsa oklahoma that's
almost sold out and big news we just
added another show in colorado springs
for june 18th boom or we are adding the
tickets are going to go on sale very
soon we're adding it right this weekend
will be updated check back on the
website for that so stop complaining we
hear you
okay only a little solo thingy going on
oh yeah it's vegan and julia keegan yeah
and juliet illinois is it joliet or
julia julia i always think julia jake
from blues brothers i assume it's the
same thing because it's outside of
chicago right her name's gonna be julia
gullia yeah that's funny
julia
really
all right i like the wedding singer i
like oh it's a great movie it's a great
film
all right shut your mouth i'm gerald's
more of a jack and jill guy oh yeah he
loves it how dare you
oh yes i'm a woman now see who i am oh
yeah my mother would do the same voice
that my jewish character does and all my
other voices
told booth i'm jack i'm chilling
all right
i'm big in china yeah i'm very big in
china
that's why i do 50 movies a year that
are basically vacations
i love that
i do love that he goes on vacations with
all of his friends on the company's dime
yeah he's like no i do like this
romantic comedy but should it be set on
an african safari yes it should adam
said
the next the next elon musk space launch
is gonna be adam sandler david spade and
terry crews with a gopro
what are they uh all right yeah just
it's for the movie that's one hell of a
licensing deal yeah just what's kevin
james yeah just uh fitting right into
that farley roll
okay so this is something i was i was
going over that i don't remember exactly
when i started going over this but you
know let me start this off with jimmy
carter's awful yeah just the pits worst
president in history you say modern
american modern american history for
sure you know you go back far enough i
don't know you go to woodrow wilson and
yeah honestly i don't really know a
whole lot about william mckinley but i
assume he wasn't very good
wasn't there one for like a day
or a week like what was the shortest run
no that was the uh you're thinking of
the
solar eclipse and you're actually that
was just test holiday on the diving oh
that was right don't look directly at
her right i thought she was the
president
the breaking board yes
yes
like i thought you were on a high dive i
was yeah well i almost got up there but
you're in the water yes
oh that's a high fall how does that
happen
can't you see i'm anorexic
oh that's why all the water is now out
of the schools
who was that louis what's his name that
did the high dive thing when they did
splash with all the uh things and he
like rolled off and that was his dive i
just didn't know you're talking about
back to school with ronnie no no no no
no no
no no it's a game show it's uh louis
something really really big comedian guy
oh uh andrew anderson yeah louie
anderson they had a guy
they were like you got to like do a dive
and they actually judge you for it i
don't think it made it more than i'm
high diving
trying to find that's pretty hilarious
the way william harrison was president
for almost a month 31 days william
harris that's what i was thinking yeah
it was like some insane low number all
right that's right somebody kidnap his
daughters do we all have to act here
like we really know a whole lot about
william harrelson harrison william
harrison i don't know someone woody
harrelson someone said this to me once
that i have listened to and then i
regurgitated as if i knew something like
me remembering how many holes in one kim
jong
there's no reason i should retain that
knowledge but i did look at the big
brain on dave but you know what would be
useful if i could remember how to
identify the coral snake versus his
imposter it's something like
red next to yellow can kill a fellow red
next to black the point is i don't
remember it as much as i remember kim
jong-un's holes in one so i'm going to
die
well if a snake's biting you and you're
just thinking about rhymes you're gonna
die yeah well hopefully it's one of
those uh dry bites that's what i do with
bombs yeah yeah blue wire
mark maguire yeah which by the way no
more shacks behind the studio deal i
know okay
manifesto still okay
just no more hoodies and glasses we'll
call it even all right all right
so jimmy carter is sucks to begin with
okay marley was dead to begin with we
all know that he was a horrible
president and we all know that he is the
reason that ronald reagan came in and
was one of the most beloved presidents
in modern american history despite not
being all that conservative ronald
reagan okay there's no hero worship for
ronald reagan here i certainly think it
was better than jimmy carter now uh
this is not just something that i'm
saying i know if you read the new york
times they now try and sort of be
apologists and say actually jimmy carter
wasn't that bad but that's about as good
as they can give you because it's been
pretty widely agreed upon that um he's
been bad but now
even the media and not because they're
being truthful but because they're
trying to save their own ass is
acknowledging that former vice president
biden may be inching carter out
americans have lost their confidence in
president biden and their optimism for
the country at least they have right now
just 22 percent of adults say we're
headed in the right direction a shocking
71 percent say we're on the wrong track
only three in 10 americans only 30
percent say bidens of policies have
improved the economy 45 percent say the
hell are they
no wonder the president's approval
rating according to a survey released
this week by quinnipiac university
stands at just 33 percent
confidence in the economy dropped 10
points over the last year to just 33
percent that is a major decline from the
68 percent satisfaction
back in 2020 before he didn't says more
than half of americans think president
biden will go down as one of the worst
presidents in american history come on
man look at that that's crazy that's
that's 11 points more than president
trump oh well i guess if he tweeted more
it'd be 12 or 15 points more yeah that's
really you know he'd really be bad
yeah so uh uh i'm trying to think here
of exactly how to look i don't put much
faith in polls okay just to be clear but
the fact is those polls change
dramatically which means that even if
you don't trust polls you have to
acknowledge the media at some point is
it's either the polls have shifted or
the media is going ooh
we want to distance ourselves from this
guy either way objectively he is doing
pretty badly right so before he was
doing anything we thought 68 thought he
was doing good the minute he started
doing stuff it's like ooh that's not so
bad and the minute those things started
having the effect on you that they're
having now you're like oh crap so let's
go through a few key details exactly how
they compare and it's it's it's uh
it's almost a mirroring of jimmy carter
and i think this is important because
i've talked about this in the past where
uh especially with millennials
generation z
we never really had a a reagan we never
really had a more conservative or
limited government president we had
george w bush we had bill clinton we had
george w bush we had barack obama they
were they were all relatively similar
right they were all sort of
two sides of the same coin yeah whereas
he had a pretty clear contrast with
carter and reagan when people say okay
boomer keep in mind this is the flower
power generation they were putting
daisies in uh you know military rifles
just to be clear
then they became the most conservative
generation or one of the most
conservative generations ever why
because they saw the contrast boom
carter they said uh-uh reagan elected
him in a landslide re-elected him in a
landslide uh and then they said okay
that's
that's the ticket that uh that that i
want from here on out this generation
hasn't really had that yet but i think
there's a pretty clear contrast now you
had eight years of barack obama everyone
acknowledges donald trump certainly a
different three years i'm not counting
that last year because there was a
manufacture because there was an
overblown
a panic crisis pandemic that came from a
bat
somewhere in the world uh and now we're
back to basically the same
administration right this guy this is
the former vice president so eight years
three and now we're gonna have another
four
there's value in that now let's compare
biden
to carter what do we have sky high gas
prices right energy prices overall oil
is well over a hundred dollars a barrel
as of this morning it's 431 as the
national uh gosh average price for a
gallon of gas four dollars and 31 cents
the highest that it has been in this
country i think it's like 580 something
right now in california the average i
know the highest is like seven in
certain places right 580 something as
the average i believe is what i looked
at this which by the way did you see on
the jon stewart podcast they were
sitting there and they couldn't find an
answer they were saying uh why do you
think that uh why do you think it's so
high in uh you know so high in
california and they're like oh it's
because people have to drive everywhere
have you heard of texas yes by the way
bring that map back up look at this map
look at look at the places that are
highest red is the highest
right the middle of the country there in
the conservative places the lowest
there's a lot of land to cover there
which by the way is a really shitty map
because they're showing the blue states
as red yeah well they're just trying to
trick you that's a just a little
subtlety there so uh this is a direct
result right with buy and of course we
know about keystone xl not just keystone
but keystone xl we know about his
limiting of drilling uh here in the
united states no more onshore uh leases
and of course look it's more complicated
than how much oil do we have right now
it's a speculative market but the point
is oil is more expensive and we have a
president who wants to transfer us to
green energy that just isn't in the
cards right now that's why everything is
more expensive how do you know because
he said it okay now as a result and this
is what i just saw this report this week
oh that's that's that's the exact thing
that's the jimmy carter thing yeah as a
result the media trying to carry the
water for former vice president joe
biden well rather than tell you look
this is a major screw up from this
administration and uh you know the 70
something percent of you who think that
we're worse off are correct
they want you
they want you the uh the you know not
the bourgeoisie the proletariats i
believe i'm using that correctly they
want you to
change your driving habits the pain at
the pump hitting americans in the
pocketbook
it's stressful you know it keeps going
up
gas prices reaching a record high an
average of 417 a gallon some tips to
keep your wallet from hitting e higher
starting with the way you drive
aaa says try to group your trips
together accelerate gradually avoiding
jackrabbit starts anticipate your stops
when approaching a red light let your
foot off the gas as early as possible on
the interstate experts recommend
reducing your speed i just drove back
from tampa to chicago i went 68 miles an
hour i got 32 miles a gallon when i
bumped it up six miles an hour it went
down to 29 miles a gallon and try not to
leave your car idling
oh try not to leave it hey how many uh
how many miles per gallon do i get if i
run you reporters over
shift into neutral when you hit a hill
and like flattening you like a penny on
a train track
learn how i don't mind
figuratively figure it out yeah yeah you
want to do a slow acceleration yeah what
if i have to go real fast
i mean it's not like i'm always just
slowly accelerating over your foot
sometimes i have to get somewhere
figuratively i drove a ridiculous amount
at six to eight miles an hour longest
drive of my life better gas mileage
though yeah yeah i was going two under
everyone was angry yes that's how you
should drive all the time also because
i'm uh because i'm an absolute [ __ ] i
was driving in the left lane i got a
ticket for going slow in the left lane
and i didn't know this but they can
officially revoke my actual birth
certificate as a mail they tore it up
and the officer slugged me yes it's
totally legal yeah it's completely legal
i was very surprised because i'm very
white yeah
i said do you know who i am yeah
they said yeah you're that [ __ ] who
told us to drive eight miles slower to
save money on gas
and he hit me with his night stick now
so you see that right change your
driving habits
change your driving habits here's the
thing this isn't the first time that
it's happened it's so foreign to us
us right people who i'm in my early 30s
maybe you're in your 20s it's foreign us
because we've never experienced that
guess what
gas shortages gas lines soaring gas
prices your parents remember this under
jimmy carter yeah it happened and it
happened for a multitude of reasons
internationally we'll get to that too
some failed international policies but
it also happened because of domestic
policy and what happened as a result of
that there was a national 55 miles per
hour speed limit that's where it came
from yes it wasn't there before that you
were saying it was something else like
what was it you had so there were some
places that didn't have speed limits
they just had safe and sane was
considered the policy well that's that's
and then it was like you know bargaining
where it's like 55 and like how about 65
and then some places got 70. yeah
we so we know we don't have we don't
have there should be places with no
speed limits so we don't have an
autobahn basically no we don't have this
no damn it yeah all because of that
shitty reporter
and just go four miles less per hour oh
yeah okay during 911 people were
arrested for jacking up the gas prices
too lower than it is now right yeah
think about that
it's amazing you remember when bro oil
baron from fern gully be like that's
severe yeah come on i'm not trying to
hurt everyone yeah right barack obama
even said during his gas spike it's
weird how this happens under
democrat-controlled regime i don't
understand it he said just make sure you
air up your tires yeah you remember that
advice no he's not 100 wrong but it's
like okay fine that'll take what two
cents off like i'll gain 0.02 percent
fine it's like just make sure to air up
your tires i'm like oh yeah tell that to
uh half the senate as i'm stabbing them
well figuratively a lot of guest players
and tighty men don't know how to do that
right
just to be clear i meant tires tires not
stabbing a person even then it's
figurative we never slash a tire
just prices right
i hate
a happy face oh i won't foreign policy
well let's compare biden to jimmy carter
uh i know sorry
i just laughing because we were watching
that that's a report what did it say the
average price was four four seventeen
four seven two days ago i think it's 4
30 something today it's gone up about 50
to 60 cents in the last week i believe
yay
well i'll get fact checked by reuters
just because since coming on this show
the gas prices actually changed
you'd you'd be closer to the price at
the beginning of the show playing planko
now well i'll pay 14 a gallon just as
long as i can drive whatever tesla yeah
i'll pay an extra few dollars a gallon
so long as my driver gets me to my place
on time yep i don't care
i don't mind if my uber's fourteen
hundred dollars to go to the grocery
store
all right
so let's look at foreign policy this is
an important thing there's a lot of
there are a lot of similarities and not
just russia uh we've talked about russia
quite a bit so i just didn't want to
rehash all that today i think you know
where i stand
now biden said let's look at afghanistan
because there's a pretty good parallel
here with uh what happened in
afghanistan and what happened with jimmy
carter in iran
he said there were 100 to 200 americans
left in afghanistan former vice
president joe biden yeah then at a house
hearing kevin mccarthy said that only
5400 of 11 to 15 000 americans had been
evacuated here's the thing
we don't know the official number i want
to be clear before you fact-check we
don't know the official number of
americans who've been evacuated versus
the number of americans who uh were
there remained there
biden said there wouldn't be one
and it's certainly more than i don't
know give or take a couple dozen that
former vice president biden gave you
okay so there are still americans
stranded in afghanistan let's just agree
and it's more than former vice president
biden predicted or told you about that
parallels exactly again worst president
in history up until now jimmy carter the
iranian hostage crisis if you guys saw
argo you know about the crisis you know
about the hostage situation you know
what happened you know how it started
but what you probably don't know
is i think it was 60 something hostages
66 400 something some people were let go
but 66 hostages 44 days 44 was the
embassy right 440. and they were only
released when ronald reagan took office
oh along with the solar panels so biden
leaving effectively hostages right and
then carter same exact thing
same exact scenario just to be clear
which is also emblematic of the respect
that we have internationally keep in
mind i get that you think a lot of
people didn't like donald trump
personally but they thought he was crazy
enough to do the crazy [ __ ] he said he
was going to do yeah he would have he
would have gotten us out of afghanistan
in a much more planned way like if
you've heard them talk about it it's
like guys this was not rocket science
you don't pull out of the country at
this time of year that's when people go
to war yeah like you do it in a
different time of year and it's much
safer for everybody involved and you
know what else even just talk just
really quickly russia ukraine a lot of
people don't realize this i don't even
know how much we've talked about this on
the show you know donald trump said no
if you're gonna do you're gonna do the
uh i'm not keystone uh uh nordstrom
that's gonna you're gonna do this
through ukraine
right yeah why because it forces them to
then not bomb them
and if you and if you don't okay i'm
gonna bomb you i hope that's what i just
do you're telling me something i hope
i'm crystal clear
and putin thought like oh you're a big
talk he's not all talk just he's crazy
enough wait three years yeah
let's see what happens yeah
internationally this is what happens
when you are dependent on
the energy when you are dependent on
these co-dep when you're these
co-dependent let's call it what it is
codependency with countries that would
like to see us wiped off the face of the
map the only reason that they don't is
because we're powerful enough to
mitigate their power and we also have
democrats like carter
like uh former vice president biden who
want to eliminate our powerful standing
in the world it's just
i is it me okay let's go to inflation
this is one how does this affect you
under former vice president joe biden
you all know this uh inflation in the
consumer price indexes when you hear me
use the term cpi that's what it means
it's sort of a general measurement and
i'll come back to it because now it's
misleading the cpi now uh went up 7.9
uh through february in 2022. now you've
all heard this but just so you don't
take my word for it
this is the highest and this is key
the highest inflation rate for uh a a
quarter a month
in 40 years year over year 7.9 percent
is the inflation number that is a 40
year high month over month up eight
tenths of a percent that shows that even
month to month inflation is accelerating
it is gas it is shelter it is food
groceries all these things you basically
can't live without
are rising here so when you dig into
these numbers you can see just why so
many americans are so sour on the
economy on those opinion polls that's a
good that's a good way for me i mean
they're a little sour yeah a little sour
little tummy ache honestly no job
crippling financial woes oh it's a
little no home can't afford to drive
your kids to soccer games food too
expensive tums maybe your rolaids
leaves the bad taste in my mouth yeah
snozzberry now let's comp that's a 40
year high
do the math 40 years oh it's a 40 year
high exactly since
the embarrassment that was president
jimmy carter where the cpi rose 13.5
13.5 yeah
uh undercard in 1980. now here's the
thing that matters that a lot of people
don't understand because sometimes the
way that we
sort of like a
vaccine adverse uh reactions like we
just talked about you change the numbers
sort of like infant mortality rate when
people say we have a higher one in the
united states it's because we actually
count the lives that are lost whereas
they just say that's not a life in a lot
of other nations the cpi right the
consumer price index when we're talking
about this inflation
under carter at 13.5 that included the
rising uh cost of housing yeah which i
don't know if you've been paying
attention
kind of a big deal today so the rate
that you see of seven point whatever
percent under biden does not include
that if you adjusted for that for an
apples to apples comparison the
inflation rate would actually be eleven
percent under former first
direct responsibility for what they
called reaganomics and treated like it
was a bad thing it was like so you could
still buy a home
after what he did to the country right
well do you know what the interest rates
were then you're talking about three
four or five percent right now and
you're like oh that's crazy it was it
was in the double digits oh for sure
maybe even some cases 20 percent can you
imagine well that was like every used
car lot too where it's like you can get
a car for only 20
yeah like holy crap you have no idea
what it's like to live under the
mistakes of this kind of administration
but unfortunately we're about to find
out mel far in detroit wore a cape and
flew around and gave everybody low
prices with a 20 percent interest rate
straight on cars only like why are you
going for fun you're not super
at the time it was at the time it was it
was like only 20
yeah it was really easy how do i do it
yeah i don't know well i don't know i'm
guessing something illegal he was the
right he was the wealthiest black
businessman in the world and he owned a
car lot
garage that i overlook from my
bombed-out crack den
here
at 20 that's a good deal
that's what i'm telling you sign me up
that's what i told you honey they had to
tell don gooly cadillac to stop letting
dry dealers pay him in cash because they
didn't want the high interest rates
they're like you really are taking a lot
of cash for brand new eldorados
no paper trail he just handed me a lot
of money with blood on it yeah there's
your fleetwood still spins like this
anthrax or
just coco yeah okay fine i was worried
so uh we've gone through it we've gone
through inflation we've gone through uh
international policy we've gone through
gas prices by themselves energy prices
because inflation is is something that
affects everything and the energy prices
are something that sort of exists
well they exist as a portion of
inflation but um it's an entirely
different beast altogether when it's
this bad and keep in mind too that with
the rising cost of energy there's that
rubber band effect so you're going to
see very likely far worse inflation and
you'll see them try and massage the
numbers to tell you that it's not that
bad kind of like when they told you
inflation was a good thing but now
they're telling you that they're going
to
do something to get costs down and bring
that why do you need to do that if it's
a good thing again none of this makes
sense so this brings us to another
comparison
uh
the disastrous results and this is this
is the silver lining folks okay the
disastrous results of jimmy carter led
to what led to what led to what
midterms and in those midterms they have
these numbers in front of me was plus
three right they gained uh republicans
gained three seats in the senate they
gained 15 in the house and there were
six
republican governor wins yeah plus six
republican governors that was considered
until like barack obama that was
considered an unbelievable shift in
midterms well and you're about to see it
again that's the okay big time so
this brings me to my point midterms
jimmy carter we don't have them yet
but even the media at this point
is trying to soften the blow it's what
psychologists call front loading by
letting you know that
this is going to hurt
president biden will enter his second
year in office after the new year but he
faces a big test can he and democrats
hold on to their power the 2022 midterm
elections are expected to be tough for
democrats according to an average of
polls by 538 mr biden's approval rating
has dropped to the lowest phase the nbc
news poll at the end of last year and
i'll show you where things were so on
direction of the country 70 percent
lacking in big time
territory you look at the presidential
job rating as of our last poll here hang
on a minute and as you can see his
approval sitting at 42 again that would
put
democrats in shellacking territory in
april it was 88.3 americans were really
pretty good about the direction early in
the bible administration they thought
covid was getting better they thought
the economy was getting better you look
at this number now 70.3 from april to
august that's a that's a big drop on
number two it's worth that number it's
roughly everybody it's below 80 the
democrat the incumbent party needs to
worry 31 of iowans approve of how joe
biden is handling his duties as
president while a whopping 62 percent
disapprove this poll then is rightly
understood as a where where where
blaring red alarm for not lacking but
especially down ballot democrats in iowa
and elsewhere who will be running in the
2022 midterms don't you also love how
the media just assumes that this
concerns you because
these are warning bells no these are
victory bells [ __ ] people don't under
they assume they're like isn't this
terrible and a lot of no 61 percent are
saying that's why i said what i said i'm
one of the 16 what are you talking about
who are you talking to things are about
to get better alarm is what's going on
or they're about to get less worse well
yeah well
less horrible gosh if they come in and
don't do anything i'm just like all
right i give up on you yeah republicans
yes yes i'm just cleveland i have some
balls last guy out yes well that dollar
for gas and money in the bank
hell don't get me started on those
snippy tweets oh low unemployment who
needs that he said a sexual thing on a
bus once yeah i know
that the son of a bee sting and honestly
it even
kind of sounded fun so
was that billy figuratively
billy who billy bush yeah yeah billy
billy unemployed who wouldn't want to
impress billy bush exactly
he's just trying to make conversation
with billy bush what would you talk
about what if he was nervous looking
himself in the mirror before like gotta
impress mr bush
you only get one first impression
grabbed by the [ __ ] right
oh no did i oversell it
i did it wrong aren't i a card
all right
[Laughter]
i'm sorry billy i'm sorry really i'm in
i'm encouraging excuse me i'm
incorrigible right you want to be my
friend we have to have the
self-conscious trump skit yeah that
never happened oh ever exactly that's
what's funny no that's why you say
ascendant's like that because there's no
subconscious aspects
i bet you donald trump was on the set of
home alone too and they're like okay and
action the bathroom's over there
i did it done like sinatra ocean
they haven't even they haven't even
checked the gate
halfway down the hall
let's just tape them now it's fine so
this brings me to this is a bonus point
here too that i realized uh actually
someone else here brought it to my
attention
you know jimmy cart voter fraud now i'm
not referring to at all the safest and
most secure election in history if
you're not a member of mud club lot of
credit dot com club we'll talk about
that a little bit more later
but here on you for all intents and
purposes uh on youtube
best election ever best yeah yeah
i'm such a huge fan yeah is the
godfather two of elections
yeah
of that there can be no debate so
uh
jimmy carter was very concerned though
on an unrelated note with mail-in voter
fraud he was so concerned with voter
fraud and election integrity that jimmy
carter actually formed the commission on
federal election reform
uh which produced by the way 2005 fraud
voter fraud report this was something
that he was very concerned about and
another parallel
up until he was told to not say these
things anymore and so he said them for a
little bit longer but then eventually
stopped
former vice president joe biden was
really concerned with voter fraud and
election integrity secondly we're in a
situation where we have put together and
you guys
did it for our administer the president
obama's administration
before this
we put together
i think the most
extensive and inclusive
voter fraud
organization in the history of american
politics well hold on a second
why would you need that joe
yeah do you mean anti-voter fraud it
doesn't exist
we now know this we've put together the
greatest voter fraud team in the entire
world i mean uh uh ant anti vote yeah
that's what it's like putting a guy in
charge of curing cancer who thinks it's
a myth yeah
[Laughter]
i mean it's just the point is right look
they both so you can comment below let
me know if there's a comparison here if
there's a similarity that you think i've
missed but to recap it under jimmy
carter we had a horrible economy it hurt
who the middle class the most we had
unbelievable taxes we had unbelievable
inflation our our standing in the uh the
global marketplace was far worse to the
point where there was a landslide
election almost unprecedented with
ronald reagan and then of course you saw
this re-election with him we have this
exact same contrast right with donald
trump only in reverse and president joe
biden former vice president joe biden
president barack obama thing is here we
have donald trump an outsider sandwiched
between eight
years of former vice president biden and
his ilk
and then another four years and i do
think it will be four years i i it
there's no i mean unless you know unless
uh his voter fraud organization isn't
worth its salt
it gets into high gear
i believe you can understand the
implication
these guys are terrible he's the most
popular president ever you know what
pisses me off too we said this we knew
this going into it we told you this was
going to happen donald trump is looking
like he's clairvoyant calling the shot
before it happens seven dollar gas is
heading your way like we knew this was
gonna happen how did you think this was
going to end also i grabbed clairvoyant
[Laughter]
lottery.com uh if you want to buy some
of these shirts
i'm sorry
i hate the jimmy fallon that i just i
couldn't
it was worth it i gave it the old
college try yours was genuine his is not
no no so who could have seen this coming
uh half the country
if not more
people wanted to be right
careful i mean
not not what i mean is coming
almost half the country well more less
than half saw this coming and voted for
the guy they thought would prevent it
then have voted for anybody in history
other than the guy running right that
guy the only people who could have seen
this coming were 18 out of the 19
bellwether counties which no president
has won and lost an election since 1980.
my point is there are some people who
could have seen this coming but not
enough to have
voted for the man in record numbers uh
who said this was coming so let's just
be really clear all reference is
available at loudercrowder.com i hate
big tech so much i hate that this is
where we are where people have to be
careful with the truth tess holliday has
to be less careful telling people that
she's anorexic and that people should
go to their doctor and [ __ ] about
discrimination
if he says you might not you might want
to be less than 400 pounds she is less
worried about medical misinformation
than we are reporting on documents from
the fda by court order that's the world
you live in i think you should have
actors playing doctors when they go in
yeah like not actual medical
professionals patrick dempsey
yeah just walk in and they're like oh
i'll play and make believe uh this room
yeah exactly someone's doing actual
surgery i'll pretend you're anorexic
just like some actor who needs a
character device who's always using the
defibrillator the paddle like yeah well
we're losing him ah i'm just here for a
it's a george clooney yeah
back when you're still doing the head
bob are we still on youtube by the way
we've said some you know very true thing
very true i mean we're still on i know
we're still on tick tock which is
incredible because we're actually trying
to yes so this is something we have
actively been trying to get removed from
tick-tock
because i don't like the communist
chinese and unfortunately we just keep
racking up because we've been banned
from tick tock like four times yeah and
now once we started this this mission
and this hashtag trash tick tock we just
rack up tens of millions of views so
we're going to go
all in today
because i have failed you it's time to
trash tick tock
[Laughter]
my gosh how do they do this on a honda
cub with nine chicken coops they don't
wear the headphones
they just make them
yeah so here's the thing i've been
trying to get banned from tick tock
really quickly now uh tick tock just put
in some new rules i want to make sure
that it should be helpful new rules
about misinformation okay
which helps us here
misinformation well i'll read i'll read
it as the writers of son of a [ __ ]
i'll read it as the writers for tick
tock probably
the misinformation is defined as content
that is inaccurate or false we will
remove misinformation that causes
significant harm to our individuals
community or the larger public
regardless of intent significant harm
includes serious physical injury illness
death severe psychological trauma
broad scale property damage
and on the mining of public trust in
civic institutions and processes
processes how would they say i don't
know processes such as governments
erections and scientific bodies like
like a wuhan lab or the communist party
ruling china other than that son of a
[ __ ] this is a very hard you know what
guys yeah take it off
take it off but hey
budget for another rice paddy hat
did you even hear that oh no it looks
like a bonnet like a little house
[Laughter]
i assume you still have the uh the
stereotypical music okay it's playing
yes all right tick tock and it's
[Music]
brilliant you ready
this is going on tick tock right ready
okay
there you go
from uh 1279 to 1368 china was ruled by
the mongols
tick tock
during world war ii mao's kami's hid
away in the hills like the cowards that
they were while chinese nationalists
fought the japanese also uh mao's
commies that killed millions of people
during the cultural revolution
taiwan's gdp per capita is nearly three
times larger than china's
because they're better than you
communist chinese party just to be clear
not the citizens of china
by communist chinese party i mean owners
of tick tock uh
china is the third worst country by the
way in the world for human trafficking
at the beginning of the coveted outbreak
which china cost uh landlords in uh
guangzhou kicked dozens of africans out
of their homes for no apparent reason
just so you guys know so that's just in
case you thought that there was no
racism in china uh china steals about
600 billion dollars worth of ip from the
united states every year
tick tock you know this is true
tick tock i'm on your platform you
better come out and pound me
[Laughter]
chinese street vendors use gutter oil to
cook their food commonly referred to as
human [ __ ]
china loves uh harvesting organs from
plethora of minority groups
sorry just thought it was funny okay i
don't know why
jeet kune does dumb and mike tyson would
kick the ever loving crap out of bruce
lee now here's something i just i really
this is also a problem i have to
navigate this so the next few facts that
i have again the hashtag is trash tiktok
so please go i want all of you to do
your best as well
uh the next few facts that i have
pertaining to the
the new tiktok rules are actually not
only a violation of tick
but could be a violation of youtube
specifically uh specifically so this is
the thing you don't think that they're
working you don't think that they're in
cahoots
they're three doors down from each other
at least i assume they have an audience
there is the undermining of public trust
in civic institutions and processes such
as government's elections and scientific
bodies now i don't necessarily know how
that works because some of the things
that i want to say it's about the
communist chinese government and the
american communist government um
so i want to be banned from tick tock
but i don't want to be banned from
youtube so we're going to continue this
segment and then of course upload it to
tick tock on mug club just not on
youtube so leave a comment below uh if
you want to let the tick tock overlords
know that you hate them it's chat
thursday lot of credit.com club youtube
you know exactly why you can piss off